the ukrainian do you believe that the
the christians from ukraine that they
love the christians from russia they
pretend to be so in love with the
ukraine
pastor jesse tell me this when you
mention god
uh i sincerely want to know do you do
you believe that jesus is actually
god they're not answering that question
yes however the quran has it ever been
written in in the muslim book this is
what a lot of conservative christians
actually believe
and i can show you the evidence that the
bible that you're assumed that you are
also acknowledging has been changed you
have this war going on between the
russians ukraine's and the whole world
understands now
greetings of peace welcome to the d show
i'm eddie your host and my next guest
reverend jesse lee peterson jesse lee
patterson radio and tv show host
reverend jesse lee peterson is an
american christian conservative radio
host pastor and broadcaster jesse
peterson hosts the program's jesse lee
peterson radio show and the fallen state
and he says amazing like this amazing
and he's
here with us on the dean show hey how
you doing danny thanks for having me on
amazing amazing how you been
how's everything with you all this world
thanks for asking it's uh thanks for uh
being on the the program the dean's show
so let's start off with me on my show by
the way thanks for coming on yeah thank
you thank you for having me i think um
we should do this more often i think you
know my my vision is real i really
believe that we need to be building
bridges how would you when you hear me
say that i mean what's your response to
that well when i hear you say we need to
be building bridges and crossing over i
don't know what you mean by that so i i
have no thought about it what do you
mean by that yeah
what i mean what i mean by that is that
i i believe we have so many things in
common and it's a shame like a lot of
times when
krish i'll sit with a christian or
you know somebody who's at the christian
faith and we'll talk about different
values we'll talk about different things
that we haven't that uh points of view
and i'll say wow we have so many things
in common and like i gave that example
to you that you know you'll have people
who'll be in two different political
parties and they'll be on totally
different sides of the spectrum but they
still find some common ground i think
that christians and muslims have far way
more in common than they than they do
differences and i think if we highlight
those commonalities and we work on those
and we nurture those i think we're going
to be able to make a difference because
there's so many different the fact you
know you talk about you know i don't
want to throw the baby out with the
bathwater right and just and you you
bring up you a lot of good topics uh i i
just went through some of some of your
work and i see you you address some
things about the family about you know
uh you know being married
in marriage you know being together in
marriage and and other good good uh good
things that islam would agree with so
that's what i'm talking about oh i got
you well my my primary issue with uh
allah islam whatever you want to call it
is that they have no love
uh they don't love the christians and
jews
and if you don't love all
you love none and
and so
on
i don't
i unders i understand that they have
been taught to be that way
is he still there
yes yes we're
listening i understand that they've been
taught to be that way
and so that's what make me skeptical
about them is that they have no love and
you can't trust an angry person
because they will deceive you turn on
you at some point
and in the quran or let them change it
they say
about the christians and jews are
infidels
and i haven't heard
any group of so-called leaders of the
muslim folks come out and denounce that
or remove that from their uh little
quran book thing
so did you did you look at my answers to
a lot of these questions that you had
you know you you mentioned these things
and i tried to politely i tried to
go and give you some references from the
text i tried to address many of your
concerns i mean how did you
did you look at my answers did you
objectively look at the things that i
brought to your
attention
uh a few of them i didn't have time to
really go through all that
uh i have interviewed different muslims
on my show at times over the years
and i've noticed that uh
they're not honest people they don't
tell the truth
because they have been told that um
from birth
that it's okay to deceive the christians
and jews you can deceive them you could
befriend them
in order to destroy them and it's okay
to lie to them in order to destroy them
and so i'm just concerned about that and
i know what
anybody that doesn't have love the love
of the father in them that they cannot
be trusted and i know that just having
lunch together is not going to solve the
spiritual issue
and so i'm concerned about that and i do
wish them well i hope they overcome that
at some point
um and then there are a lot of quote
unquote christians
who lack love as well
and it's easy to deceive them about
those things you have a big nice lunch
with them a gathering
and you make them feel good by feeding
them and telling them how wonderful they
are
then you got them as well because they
have no love so they can't see what
they're doing either okay you you bought
you brought up some legitimate concerns
and i want to
uh as
many muslims are watching here and many
uh will hear what you have to say and
many will kind of just
they're it's kind of really odd to a lot
of muslims a lot of the things that
you're mentioning but uh be it be it
that the media is powerful and the
media machine a lot of the lies have
been perpetuated for you know since
since the uh
the advent of when
the truth has been perpetuated there's
always been opposition to that truth so
i'm just i'm going to ask you are you
open is your mind open
if now we're able to discuss these
things
and
the things that you've mentioned we'll
go over them one by one and if i can if
we can bring the evidence
from the quran from the life of prophet
muhammad if we can go ahead are you
willing to adjust your views just like
i'm willing to you know i think any
person who's sincere and genuine if you
bring me something if i had a certain
view and you bring me proof and evidence
like for example if i thought one plus
one was five but you bring me evidence
that one plus one is two you know i
didn't know any better i mean i would i
would make that adjustment are you
willing to make that adjustment here
today
well i'm definitely willing to listen
and
without any personal judgment about it
uh because you can learn that way
absolutely okay so i have i have with me
also now the director of gain peace i
have dr ahmed sabio who's going to be
joining us and now you have two you have
two people two muslims because in one of
your in one of your talks you mentioned
you'd love to meet an honest muslim that
you can interview and you can ask him
these questions so now you can ask us
genuinely any questions that you want
and god willing we're going to sincerely
you know
get to the bottom of these things so we
can remove any hurdles any fears and
apprehensions that are in your way so
let's start with this i'm going to i'm
going to open it up and i'm going to ask
dr sabil dr sabil how are you
i'm doing good and i'm glad to see and
meet uh jesse how are you brother all is
well good to meet you as well thank you
great great and i do want to applaud you
for coming to the show i'm also a guest
just like you by the way but you know i
mean you are an open-minded person you
are not just uh making your beliefs uh
just from you know certain things that
you may have read you are open to come
and listen and to discuss and to
understand
for that i'm really going to applaud you
amazing thank you i appreciate that how
do you pronounce your first name again
sabil s-a-b-e-e-l
okay thank you
so dr b let's start off with this
islam
is is islam a religion based on hatred
is islam is it anywhere written in
our book in the quran
that muslims can deceive christians and
jews in order to destroy them so that's
a twofold question does islam teach
hatred of jews and christians and is it
written in the verbatim word of god
almighty the quran that it is
muslims can deceive christians in order
to destroy them
is that
yeah so when i heard that from jesse
what came into my mind when i was in
india in india i used to watch many
hollywood movies
and the only perception that i had about
in about america and americans
is that every single person is like al
capone right they wake up in the morning
they carry the weapons and they shoot
each other out and they harms the
society
that was the only perception jesse
because i never met an american i never
read the bible
never been to america before so when i
came here i realized you know what the
media the movie industry you know the
all of the social media they were
polluting my mind you know i should not
be just watching it and making up my
mind but i should be meeting people
i should be discussing i should be uh
you know uh reading the book of the
people my neighbors my classmates and
that's what i started to do
so this question that you uh just uh
mentioned
about you know islam hates the jews and
the christians and the question about
infidels and deception
you know right away the answer would be
no because i have read the quran many
times i teach the quran by the way jesse
and
i would say that there are many many
passages one passage that came to my
mind that god is a uniting humanity is
the passage
from chapter 49 verse number 13.
i will just give the translation because
you may not know arabic
this is the translation brother
god who we say allah in arabic he's
saying
addressing to all of humanity god is
saying that o mankind o humanity
i have made you from one single male and
one single female and made you into
nations and peoples and tribes that you
get to know each other
not that you may hate and despise and
disrespect each other that you get to
know each other then god says that the
best amongst you is the one who is a
god-fearing well-mannered person
so that is the basic concept of islam
that humanity god has created in
different ways not for hating and you
know despising and discriminating but to
get to know each other
right so that itself is the foundation
of our faith brother jesse
is it
is it written in the quran that
christians and jews are infidels
okay first and foremost the quran is in
arabic language
so the word infidel would not be there
the quran discusses people who have
believers and people who are
non-believers right just like you have
citizens and non-citizens of a country
just like you have christians and
non-christians
the quran also describes
those who agree with the tenants of
islam and those who
do not agree with the tenants of islam
so the word infidel is not there but if
you want to know where did the word
infidel came from
it it actually came from the christian
history
you know when the the catholics when
they want to go and occupy jerusalem and
palestine away from the muslims and the
jews
they they were the ones you know pope
innocent and pope pius
they were the ones who labeled the
muslims and the jews as infidels uh
because according to christianity
and fiddle is a person who is an enemy
of christianity
right so that the word is coming from
there not from the quran and not from
islam
so is it written in the quran that
christians and jews are infidels
no it is not as i mentioned to you has
it ever been written there because they
may have uh removed it now since so many
muslims want to live in america amongst
the christians
it may have been removed has it ever
been written
in the quran
that christians and jews are infidels
and that anyone that doesn't agree with
the moose of religion is worthy of death
and whatever it takes to deceive them
you can do that in order to destroy them
has it ever been written in
in the book you guys book that
christians and jews are infidel has that
ever been written
okay so the quran is in arabic language
so in arabic the word infidel is not
there but you're not answering
yes however has it ever been written in
in the muslim book
that christians and jews are infidel has
there ever been written in there in that
way
not that i know first time before i read
it in there man you can't tell me that
i've seen
when i've interviewed muslim we went
over that so it was there for sure maybe
they should remove it now
so so brother jesse you have the quran
in arabic then you have many many
translations
some people may have translated
unbelievers as infidels right because
the quran just like the bible it has
been translated in more than 100
languages
some of the translators are muslims some
of the translators are people of other
faith so the translation is not the
quran by the way the actual quran would
be the one in arabic that has never been
changed and in that quran you will not
find the word infidel
do you do you understand the point jesse
like yeah i understand you're
because
saying
that
been rewritten over the years so has the
bible too
um
anyone that isn't true in the muslim
religion that anyone that doesn't
believe in what they believe in are
infidels
no
no we just consider we just consider
them as unbelievers
and even for the unbelievers brother
jesse we are supposed to be living with
them in peace and tolerance and loving
peace actually not just peace and i can
give you one passage from the quran
chapter
60 verse number eight
in vegeta god is saying you know i will
just give you the translation
in which god is saying that allah does
not forbid you from those who do not
fight you because of your faith and do
not expel you from your homes from being
righteous towards them right righteous
towards them and acting justly towards
them
indeed allah loves those who act justly
so even those who are unbelievers we are
supposed to live in peace and harmony
and righteousness and love and
compassion with them because allah loves
that act
however if you want to know where the
word infidel is it's not in the quran it
is in the bible by the way
if i can quote you from the bible in
timothy
1st timothy chapter 5 verse number 8 in
the king james version it says
but if any provide not for his own and
specially for those of his own home
he has denied the faith and is worse
than an infidel
so it is there in the bible it's not
there in the quran and as i have quoted
to you we are supposed to live in peace
and harmony even those who have rejected
the faith
and there is no compulsion in islam by
the way yeah go ahead you're our guest
just go ahead i want to make sure i i
want to make you jesse just one thing i
want to make you feel as comfortable as
possible just like if you're in my home
i'd offer you uh some uh some dates i'd
offer you some uh whatever you like to
eat you know and and hopefully uh you
can when you're in chicago you can
actually visit with us in person okay
right i know i'm totally comfortable i'm
totally talking
my issue is
um i want to ask
dr sabi sabil
do do you love the jews
i mean as a muslim i'm supposed to love
and care and help all of humanity jesse
you know for that reason
if i can give you one example right you
know when prophet muhammad peace be upon
him when he moved from makkah to medina
on his journey
there were many jewish tribes more than
17 plus jewish tribes the very first
thing that he did did not expel them did
not hated them did not fight them
he wrote or he dictated a constitution
that was all-inclusive of the muslims
and of the jewish people
that islam is going to protect them
because they were the romans and they
were the and the persians they were out
to destroy the jewish people so the
prophet peace be upon him he wanted to
protect them and he gave them identity
and he gave them you know
freedom to have their own autonomy so
they thrive under the rule of islam all
throughout history if islam hated the
jews or the christians or in a quote
unquote the non-muslims
you can see all throughout the quran and
the prophetic example how islam has you
know treated and protected
not only from the quran and the prophet
example all throughout history you know
just in world war ii
one example i can give is
away from the nazis the turkish muslims
they protected 75 000 jewish people from
getting handed over to the nazis
iran protected 2000 people albania
kosovo bosnia i can give you many
examples the muslim nations
they wrote false documents the jews are
our citizens we are not going to hand
over the jews to the nazis
so that's a prime example of how what
islam teaches us
to protect every single life even the
life of jews and christians because we
are all equal at the end of the day do
you remember jesse when i gave you love
do you love the jews dr sabil
as humans yes of course do you love the
jews
i said yes
and uh and why
because allah god has created them you
know humans have been created
okay allah according to the dictionary
and and according to jesus
see jesus's language was the language of
aramaic not english not hebrew not greek
in that language of jesus the name for
god is allah illah
according to encyclopedia britannica so
when jesus when he prayed to god he did
not use the word creator or god or
elohim
he used the word allah the way that we
are using the word allah
do you agree with jesus do you agree
that jesus was a jew
by ethnicity by ethnicity he was a jew
but by the submission to the creator
anyone who submits to the creator in
arabic we say that person is a muslim
anyone who submits and worships the
creator
so he says are you saying that jesus was
a jew who worshiped a muslim
no what we are saying is
he was a believer of one god he
submitted to one god so by definition we
say that person is a muslim a muslim is
a person who submits only to one god and
prays to him and follows his
commandments do you believe that god you
believe that god is a muslim
no we say that god is the creator of all
of humanity and the whole creation
god is not going to you are a christian
who is he exactly
god is the creator and in the quran it
uh it gives many many wonderful
attributes of god
it says that he is the creator of all of
us he's eternal he does not have any
children he does not have any parents he
is all-knowing he is a loving creator he
wants to guide humanity
so it says in the quran to guide
humanity god did not came down to become
a human
he remained god and he appointed he
chose from the humans messengers and
prophets
abraham and moses ishmael and isaac
david and solomon jesus and muhammad
peace be upon them
and he gave them the revelation jesse so
they have to go and to the humanity and
invite humanity to worship of one god so
that is god in islam
amazing it just says
just to because we will move on yes
did you i mean the muslims
do not see christians and jews as
infidel
worthy to die of death and you could
befriend them you could lie to them
you're saying
that justin is this in a more muslim
muslim belief and religion right that
that's what it is
before he answers it let me just ask you
something jesse tell me is this really
like uh what because you are someone who
uh is one of the top conservative you
run one of the top conservative radio
shows in america you've been on hannity
and it was at rush limbo and uh the sat
what's the savage nation you know all
these guys right
yes yeah those are your friends these
are people who expose a lot of these
beliefs and based on a fall false
presence so do a lot of is this kind of
the thought process is this what a lot
of conservative christians actually
believe
this stuff that because a lot of muslims
now are like wow they actually believe
we believe this so do you guys do not
just you but do a lot of christians
across the board do they believe this
what you're the kind of questions that's
why it's so important is that we have
these discussions you know
do they believe
i don't know if a lot of christians
believe this because i have not uh
spoken to a lot of christians about it
yeah but i do know that there are
muslims who
have converted to christianity
and they know the muslim religion really
well and they are very honest about the
deception
of the muslim religion
and the hatred of the christians and
jews that's why when they moved to our
country from
from over there
they don't unite with the christians and
jews
because of their
uh just light just staying for them they
separate they build their own mars and
they build their own area to live in
and if you were to go in those areas not
all of them but some of them you might
get killed
but don't really
notice they don't really unite with
americans they don't stand with america
for america
and so the proof is in the pudding you
see their actions and it doesn't
demonstrate
love
for america at all dr bill you want to
comment on that yeah so brother jesse
would you like to take the us
constitution from americans or from the
russians
repeat that
if somebody asked you about the
constitution right would you rather
learn the constitution from a
knowledgeable american professor
or from a russian who may not like or
who may have moved away from the us
right naturally you want to get it from
u.s
of course i would want to
hear from someone that is an american
citizen born here right here know it
but um that's different than religion
because religion is very deceptive
and
because most people who are into
religion have wicked hearts they have
anger of the heart they're not going to
tell you the truth
about their religion
and so jesse have you read the quran by
the way because you know
the quran is the word of god and then
the example of how the prophet lived the
quran how he practiced these are the two
main sources of islam so if anyone tells
me you know what islam tells me to do
this or tells me to do that right away i
would ask that the person the question
is it in the quran the word of god is it
followed by prophet muhammad peace be
upon him so i'm going to ask you that
question have you found anything like
that in the quran brother jesse that
muslims are supposed to you know hate
this or being disabled
uh that that you're supposed to deceive
it's not there my brother it's not there
because we teach the quran this is what
we do
it's not i mean again it may not be
there now i can't argue because i'm not
looking at a quran in a while but i do
know four facts
that at one point it was there
and maybe they have removed it since you
know we'll start start to realize talk
about it
and a lot of people have gone to the
koran and seen it there for themselves
how that it's okay for the muslim to lie
is it has
about the you know who they are and
about deceiving the christians and jews
have you um
is it a muslim talk that is okay to lie
in order to deceive
you know i can give you one quotation
brother jesse and this is prophet
muhammad peace be upon him he's saying
that god said there are three people who
god is going to oppose on the day of
resurrection
first person a man who gave his word
then he betrays it
second person a man who sold a free man
into slavery
and kept the money
and third person is a man who hired
someone benefit from his labor then does
not pay his wages
so muhammad peace be upon him he said
that whoever bears you know anyone who
cheats us is not one of us
so islam is really clear that cheating
and lying and being deceitful it's not
part of islam this is so clear both from
the quran and the prophetic examples and
now jesse if you don't mind you remember
when when you had me on your program i
kind of went over these things and i
told you this concept tequila was from a
sect of shiites and they end up using
this to deceive but my question would be
uh
you know anybody who looks at the
evidences and the proofs from what dr
sabil is saying from the verbatim word
of god almighty the quran and the
example prophet muhammad this is some
any someone who takes an analytical you
know academic approach they'll see that
this is uh this is totally false but let
me ask you this jesse do the ukrainian
do you believe that the the christians
from ukraine that they love the
christians from russia
i don't know
because i've never spoken with one from
ukraine
uh so i don't know should they love them
should someone who's in invading their
country should they love the invading
the occupying force
if um
if they have been truly born of the
spirit of god
they have no other choice but to love
do that doesn't mean that you don't
defend yourself oh there you go
they have no hate so they have a right
to defend themselves
if they're being attacked absolutely
okay so they have a right to have a
right to hate okay so they have a right
to struggle and strive against the
occupying force to protect their homes
and their families correct
well i'm not sure that russia is the
occupying force whoever is whoever is
whoever's
media and our government are big liars
and they don't tell the truth
and
and i look at how
they pretend to be so in love with the
ukraine
and they care so much about it they're
so emotional about it and they go over
there and take our money
they take our war
war machines and everything while
leaving our country wide open with the
illegal aliens coming in and
and
high taxes with gas prices and
food prices and they do nothing about it
and so it's hard to know what this real
this war is truly all about they're
hiding something from us a lot of things
going on behind the scenes right so
the point i'm saying is now you see
ukrainian christians fighting with uh
christians from russia so you have two
christians fighting each other correct
who are you saying that the uh president
of ukraine is a christian
well you have pride the the primary
religion in ukraine would be
christianity right but you said that the
president of ukraine is a christian i
don't know what religion he is i don't
know about it i see no evidence that
he's a christian that's yeah i i don't
know i don't know i'm not going to say
but my my point is it's not the people
that live there
that's fighting
it's the heads of the the ukraine and
russia and the people are just trying to
stay safe they're trying to defend
themselves and i know a lot of them have
been deceived about why this war is so
they think that they're fighting
for the right reason when they're really
not
but a lot of this stems from if you look
back now and you look at because you
said that a person has a right to defend
themselves their families they have a
right to struggle and strive against an
occupying force wherever it may be what
i mean that's just common sense once you
agree if someone was to come in your
home
and try to like force you out then you'd
have a right to defend yourself no right
so then don't let me just finish the
point sorry okay but that's what he was
he was quoting you chapter of 60 uh
verse 8 of the quran that god hasn't
forbid you from dealing kindly and being
just with those who haven't fought you
uh because of your religion or driven
you out of your homes so that's the
point just
that we're trying to make is if someone
is attacking you if someone's fighting
you
how are you supposed to like uh welcome
this person in and give them chocolate
uh give them chocolate and and uh pizza
and cupcakes you know so
that's not so that's the point that
there now islam is not a pacifistic
religion that turned the other cheese go
ahead smack me and i'll you know here
gives the other one you have a right to
defend yourself but you cannot go
killing innocent women children or
whatnot
this is something that's totally you
know forbidden you have a you have
certain rights like islam is something
when you talk about hate and dr sabil
can elaborate this and you tell me if
you agree i mean islam hates injustice
you know this is something that islam
hates islam hates oppression islam hates
racism
islam hates you know disrespect to
parents islam hates immorality crime you
know intoxication rape objectification
of women gambling uh ribba interest you
know the exploitation of the poor so
there is a place for hate so god hates
these things but just because someone
might be doing it doesn't mean that we
now are going to go be violent against
somebody or whatnot just like you as a
pastor i'm sure you don't you you don't
agree if somebody is uh doing things
opposite to the bible correct you're
gonna hate those you're gonna you're
gonna hate those things that god deems
as immoral so so there is a place right
i will discern them but not hate them
let me ask so
and i agree that if you're being
attacked you're supposed to defend
yourself
but let me ask you so let me ask you so
you believe in jihad so you believe in
jihad then no i don't but you just said
it you believe someone has a right to
the no jihad
do you know what jihad means it means
which what we just described we just
gave it it's just like you saying i
don't believe in allah what you said so
if i say do you believe in hallelujah do
you believe in hallelujah no
you don't believe god is the greatest
who is hallelujah
in the church
but do you believe that god is great
that he's the greatest do you
no no i believe he is god
yeah he's god but is he greater is he
greater than the whole creation and what
do you mean about greater than well let
me ask this first before
you know more honorable you know more
loving all-knowing he's better than the
whole creation
let me ask this um about defense you
mentioned that we have a right to defend
ourselves and i agree
uh
do you agree with me
is it shane shane right
sabile eddie
the white guy
amazing amazing your first name any
right yes okay eddie do you agree with
me that in america white people are
under attack by the blacks and others
the blacks are going into their homes
they're robbing them and killing them
and raping them they're taking their
cars they're hot uh carjacking they're
knocking them out
in in subways the asians they're
knocking them out
do you agree that the white people have
a right to defend themselves from the
blacks
i mean that's that's a god-given right
every human being has a right
to defend themselves so do the white
people have a right to defend themselves
from the blacks
it doesn't we don't have to particularly
say just anybody who comes and tries to
do injustice towards you you have a
right to defend yourself your family
your property your possessions yes
so i due to white people have a right to
defend themselves from the blacks how
would you answer that yes you have a
right you can answer that about a lot
about people so i'm asking you that
about white people in america yes
everybody has people have a right to
defend themselves from the blacks i
think i answered it how would you answer
that dr bill no no no what did you say
i'm sorry how do you hear it eddie one
more time
every human being who
is being attacked by anybody be it i
just ask about every human being i ask
you about the whites and the blacks yes
do the white people have a right to
defend themselves from the blacks here
in america
yes everybody has a right to defend
themselves
about everybody man
what yeah so jesse you the white people
have a right
to defend themselves from the blacks
here in america
let me take a shot at that
let me try ellie one more time uh doctor
didn't i answer it though i said no you
included everybody white people not
everybody
do the whites have a right to defend
themselves from the blacks in america
be it yellow pink orange black whatever
color new question but i'm not i'm
saying yes that's that allah we're
talking about you're dodging the
question right now where's your honesty
if you flip it around and you say does a
black man have a right to defend himself
as a white man i said yes does the white
man have the right to defend himself
against someone trying to rape kill yes
it's it's obvious that's i don't want to
flip it around anyway you know right now
it's known
that white people are under attack by
the government
by the blacks in this country really by
the blacks in the country
due to white people in america have a
right to defend themselves from the
blacks
if anyone because if you generalize it
if you're generalizing now as if you're
saying i'm telling you
what's going on and you're not answering
if you're saying all black people
i understand you i didn't say all black
people not all not all not all but most
and so i didn't say oh i simply asked if
you're defending i'm not about people so
well
i'm asking you in america and you're an
american right ready yes
do the black peop white people have a
right to defend themselves from the
blacks in america
if jesse peterson came to attack me in
my house and he's black i have a right
to defend myself yes why is it hard to
say yes why people have forgotten to
defend himself i just said yes man if
you come in my house to attack me i have
a right to defend myself jesse but
you're not answering the
yeah everybody watching man you're not
answering the question you're you're
skirting around the question
but you're into the outlaw about stuff
and you said just remember about that
but you're not sure about whites
protecting themselves in america from
the blacks i just said every human being
be it white i didn't ask you about every
human being
i answered the question jesse no you
didn't
so jesse yesterday
yeah suppose if you come to my family
and attack my family i will not take a
look at if you're white black brown you
know pink
i would defend myself my family and my
honor in the same way if a black person
comes to you or a white person you would
not say you know what this is black
leave him alone this is white you know
let me attack him back
you would say you know what matters at
that point
is that the safety of myself and my home
the race doesn't matter because your
question is a loaded question
he's trying to what eddie is trying to
do is he's trying to avoid the race card
but saying
every life is precious it is god given
it is equal every soul every blood is
equal so doesn't matter who is the
oppressor race doesn't matter who is the
oppressed race doesn't matter what
weapon is used that doesn't matter
we have to protect
we have because life is sacred because
it says in the quran you know jesse
chapter 5 verse number 32
that taking one innocent life
is like taking the life of all of
humanity and god does not say the life
of a black a white a brown or anyone
else so in that sense we should be
thinking every person has the right to
defend themselves against anyone they
could be of any faith any color and any
um
and any background
just yeah you are just to be
in america white people are under attack
by the blacks and others
and especially the blacks not all not
all but most
do white people in america dr should be
have a right to protect themselves from
the blacks in america
you know if you make it like all of
black because your question assumes
not all not all not all but most
do
white people have a right to protect
themselves from the blacks in america
if blacks are the oppressors if right
the what if is there if blacks are the
oppressors and if if
whites are the ones being oppressed then
definitely every person in the whole uh
you know all of humanity should defend
the whites on the flip side if some
white people are the oppressors and the
black our brothers and sisters from the
african background if they are the ones
who are being oppressed the whole
humanity should come and protect the
oppressed
so let me restate my question because
i'm asking you guys where you've been
you're telling me where you're going
dr
sebel
in america white people we all notice
are under attack especially by the
blacks
do white people have a right to protect
themselves from the blacks
brother jesse do you have the data to
support what you're saying are you
getting america
you just cannot say you know white
people are under attack and black people
of course of course you don't have to
have the problem
no i don't see that what i see that what
i see
there are always incidents in which a
person from the white background brown
background people of different face
they're good and the bad apples and the
followers of any faith so we cannot
generalize any race any religion any
nationality and say you know what white
if they're doing this and blacks if
they're doing that that's amazing that
you guys are too afraid or i either
don't love the whites enough to be
honest about this let me let me i want
to ask dr dr sabir uh you said that life
is pressure what are you precious
precious what do you mean by that
what it means so this is i'm quoting
from the quran chapter 5 verse number 32
god is saying that to save one life is
like saving all of humanity and to take
one life it's like you're taking the
life of all of humanity
that means god created this life
especially the human life doesn't matter
what race what religion and what
nationality every life is life is
precious in the eyes of god that means
we are supposed to take care of each
other remove the oppression from each
other uh and we are supposed to live in
peace and loving harmony with each other
jesse let me ask you this let me get
this
when you say we're supposed to save each
other's
uh
that god god believe
save them in what way
suppose if my neighbor is getting
attacked by some gang for example they
want to break down the door i may go and
physically protect my neighbor or i may
call 9-1-1 or i may do something else so
i can save the life of my neighbor away
from these oppressors
but that's not what god meant about save
because if that's true
god allow
the the children of of the devil
to destroy themselves to kill themselves
physically kill themselves
and what god meant about
save and spiritually save the heart from
uh from the devil he doesn't mean
physically god will let you die he'll
let you be homeless he'll let you walk
around looking crazy
he'll let you live on the streets
because he has made a way for you to
return to him spiritually and once you
return to him spiritually he will
protect you both spiritually and
physically so god is not into the
pressure thing as you're saying that's
not true about god let me ask you this
because i've burned the whole baby in
this city of gamora solomon gamora
god destroyed women
children
and men because they were of the devil
so he's not into the depression thing
let me ask you this
go ahead doctor yeah so god is given as
a free choice
of our free choice if we come towards
good follows the one god the way jesus
moses abraham used to follow and do good
deeds
they would be good consequences the
reward if a person of their own choice
are into drugs and you know doing all
the wrong things killing and homicide
and suicides then obviously there would
be consequences
so god is not forcing anyone to do
anything god has given us a choice but
suppose if it's up to me to save a
person or to just leave him
you know let him die
by the hands of the oppressed
i will try to protect and save that
person that's what it means that life is
precious we should be out there as a
force of goodness in the society are you
willing to save them let me get to that
let me get a question in jesse uh pastor
jesse tell me this when you mention god
uh i sincerely want to know do you do
you believe that jesus is actually
god the father or do you believe he was
sent by god
what is not when we're taught
without a doubt jesus christ is the son
of god
and god's nature his spirit dwelled and
steered us in him
in order that he may get the work
done on earth become the light of the
world
and
christ made it
clear that he wasn't god he said i'm the
son of god i was set by god
and greater worship that i'm doing that
you should do
he will go to the father and pray
and seek his will
and so
if god would god he wouldn't go to
himself to seek his own will he would
know his will so he's clearly
the son of god and not god can you tell
me what you when you say son of god so
we can just have a better understanding
because you know the the human mind
understands when you say sun you
understand you can have a literal son
you can have an adopted son
or metaphorical these are the three
options so what do you mean and you're
the right man for the job because you're
a pastor so just respectfully asking you
and these are the conversations that
we're talking about us having to
understand each other better so what do
you actually mean that jesus was the son
of god can you please elaborate on that
yeah i will but are you saying people
are so dumb that when they hear that
jesus christ is the son of god they
don't understand what a son is
well that's the
these are the options so you can have a
literal son of god so are you saying he
was literally the begotten son of god
was he an adopted son or was he is this
metaphorical and the reason i'm asking
is well let me and i'll tell you uh
after you yeah because the question
doesn't make sense
no actually what eddie is trying to ask
is a nice emotional question but it
doesn't make sense like for let me let
let me go people know the difference
between a son and a father and this is
this is and this is again we love jesus
as a mighty messenger if you say any uh
disrespectful thing about jesus as a
muslim you can go straight to the
hellfire i just want you to know that i
mean
there's no playing around you know we
get offended if you offend jesus so well
yeah y'all won't defend white people in
america but listen
so we know that uh dogs have puppies you
know cows have calves uh cats have
kittens so when you say god had a son
please elaborate what do you mean
god
sent his son
um jesus christ
through mary
so that we the people
the people who were lost they had no way
back to the father because adam believed
in the woman after she believed in the
devil
and so the woman became the man's god
and the devil became the woman's god
and as a result there was no way back to
the father to god
and every man every human being that
born through the woman
uh are dying they're born of the devil
and so what christ did he needed a man
to come that was not of the woman but of
the father
and so he created his son jesus christ
put his spirit in him and sent him
through the woman so that all who
believe in the son
will believe in the father and that's
why we're urging
boys and girls men and women
to return to their earthly fathers
by not resenting them forgiving them for
not protecting them from their mothers
because mothers turn the children away
from their fathers
and they recreate their children in
their image which is of the devil
and so when the kids return to the
earthly fathers
they will return to god they have to
forgive their mothers for turning them
away from their fathers and recreate
them in their image
and returned to their earthly father
forgive the father for not protecting
them
from the mother
because they didn't understand the
spirit of the mother and so once you
love your earthly father you can love
god but if you don't love your earthly
father
you would never ever ever love god you
would not know him you'll read about him
and intellectually learn that way but
you won't know him you won't have a
personal relationship with him you're
just to be an emotional intellectual
talking about god when in reality you're
a hypocrite and pharisee because you
don't know god and you keep other people
away from him
dr seville you want to uh yeah i just
want to say you know uh i'm i'm not sure
brother jesse if you know what we
believe about jesus
i don't think you may know it so i can
quickly ask you this question right uh
when eddie is saying that you know a son
can be taken as either a literal way or
a metaphorical way
i i'm assuming that you take jesus to be
a literal son of god do you
jesus christ was the son of god
even when he lived on earth in the
physical body
he was still the son of god dwelling in
jesus jesse answer the question jesse
come on just father yes
yes or no
respectfully jesse come on you know how
you come on me we're buddies now so we
can do this come on what do you mean by
literally the sun what do you mean by
that sure sure so according to the bible
according to the eastern bible
dictionary i read the bible many times
by the way just to let you know
according to
i read the bible many times so i'm just
quoting you from the bible dictionary
and also from the bible
there are many many places where the
bible mentions about a son of god in a
metaphorical way
for example according to the eastern
bible dictionary if you go under the
label son of god or sons of god it says
anyone who is a righteous person is
called as a son of god
so for that reason brother jesse if you
look into the old testament the book of
psalms chapter number 2 verse number
seven it says that david was the
begotten son of god
jacob was the son of god even adam is
called as the son of god in luke chapter
3 verse number 38 so since the word son
is there do you take them as literal or
metaphorical
well because and you're right all who
have returned to the fathers are sons
and daughters of god
and
uh christ and god is a spirit
so spiritually
jesus christ is the son of god who lived
here a monster for a while in the
physical body
and so
i hope hopefully that answer yeah he is
the spiritual
son
of god
so so not in a literal way so i mean
jesus is no different than david and
jacob
and adam because they're all sons of god
from a biblical point of view any
righteous person is called as a son of
god only if they've been born of god if
they have not been born of god they're
not sons of god they're sons and
daughters of the devil
right so the bottom line is there are
many many sons of god in the bible and
jesus is no different that's the point
we are trying to get
on
what do you mean he is no different
yeah because he's just like david who is
also called as the begotten son of god
he's just like jacob who is also
metaphorically son of god and like adam
who's also metaphorically a son of god
see god see
there are only two categories in in this
whole universe
one is the creator
anyone anyone who is not a creator is
called as the creation
so jesus is a creation of god in a
metaphorical way people may say he's the
son of god you say jesus is just the
creation of god
see
there is a creator and anything else
anything who anyone who is not a creator
what is the name for that person
he's a creation you and us you and i we
are a creation we are not creators
if jesus is not god that means he is not
god he is a creation of god
so in that sense jesus was a human he
was a prophet the way that jesus said
that i am a prophet of god many many
times in in in the bible
so we say that god gave a message to
jesus about inviting people to worship
only one god
which is there in in the quran chapter 3
verse number 51
jesus is saying and this is god is
quoting
so jesus is saying
verily allah is my lord and your lord
worship him alone and that is the
straight path
but the amazing thing brother jesse is
exactly similar thing is mentioned in
mark chapter 12 verse number 28
a person comes to jesus and he asked him
a million dollars are you ignoring quote
scriptures with no meaning there is no
meaning intellectually intellectually i
know that you think you have meaning i
know that you think but you just quoted
the bible like any intellectual
preaching
uh a so-called expert would do they
learn look at the preachers and
and they are
uh catholic priests and all those
they're hypocrites they quote the bible
but
on the inside the glass is dirty it's
evil they are diligent what is the
meaning
with all this mess
but inwardly their hearts are far away
from god and that's why the people
suffer
because the people listen to it
never really seeking father from within
so let us give the context to the
passage which i am going to quote mark
chapter 12 verse 12. you saw like
annie oh you're doing quote bible but
you're not giving me any understanding
at all does he sound like no
understanding about what you're saying
does he sound like a black black
preacher do all they do is quote the
bible yeah hey hey does he sound like a
black preacher also you sound like a
black intellectual preacher
[Laughter]
yeah so
you got to do this all you're doing is
quoting the bible in the quran but you
have no understanding about with no
insight at all what you're talking about
let me ask you something comment says
jesse uh dr sabil please don't lose your
place if me and you are driving in a car
and i am the driver and i'm the one
who's speeding and then i say jesse
tells me hey man can you slow it down or
whatnot and i'm just like trying to get
us you know the lunch when you come to
chicago i'm taking lunch and i'm
speeding police pulls us over would it
be fair and right that the police the
policeman came over to your side of the
car and gave you the ticket for me
speeding is that is that just is that
fair jesse
no that's not fair
okay so now that takes me to the main
point
of the question do you believe in
original goodness that every human being
was born in original goodness or that
now they are born in original sin that
they are stained from the beginning and
that they're being blamed for something
that they didn't do
what do you mean by boy and or original
goodness i don't know what that mean
original goodness dr bill you want to
take it away
yeah see
original goodness means god has created
all of us with a free choice with a
clean heart no blemish pure and innocent
that's what islam says see islam says
brother islam is a rational
really uh you know fair faith islam says
that no child no human can be blamed as
a evil person or a sin in a sinful
person if the person has not committed
any sin
so according to islam every new born
baby is a sinless individual
later on if they commit a sin pass the
age of puberty that's one that's when
they would have the consequences
so islam says that every child is born
with a good heart with a good mind pure
and innocent that's what eddie is saying
and that seems to be fair and just in
any court of law you cannot blame any
person to be a sinner or a law breaker
if the person has not committed that
that's what he's saying
does that make sense jesse does not
jesse does that make sense does it make
sense
this is very simple
that children are born innocent but they
are born into sin what caused sin
meaning that they are born into crazy
families where the fathers and the
mothers are no good
and so
uh
that's why all who are born of the woman
all
must be born of the father they must be
born you have wants to to live and wants
to die right once the diet wants to live
and so
all who are born of the woman is born
into sin
the woman is angry at the father she's
angry at her mother her father she hates
the kid's father and so she imposes her
demon or devil will upon the children
turning them away from the father
recreating them in their image and
that's where the sin is because the kids
start to hate the mother become angry at
the mother for imposing her will on them
and that's when they start to commit
quote-unquote sin because their hearts
are changed from love to hate they take
on the identity of the mothers
when they
return to the father the hearts are
changed back from hate to love
which is of god and not of the woman
because the women don't have real love
the love that women have is emotional
love that comes from satan that's why it
doesn't work so everybody born innocent
but they're born into crazy messed up
families where the women are in charge
and that turns you away from the father
so so you agree with us every child is
born with a clean slate no sin no
blemish and obviously we have a friend i
told you we got a lot in common jesse
i told you jesse
hallelujah that makes sense right
hallelujah
god is the greatest
that's not a war cry jesse that's just
praising the most high that's it jesse
she's the guy that won't defend white
people what a mess amazing
um so let me ask do you agree with dr
shabil
that all who are born of the woman are
born into sin
what do you mean interesting
meaning that they're innocent until
their mothers
because they're born into families where
the father is not the head of the wife
and the wife is not obeying her husband
they are born into a screwed up family
and they become like what they the kids
become like whomever make them angry and
if you notice a lot of men are emotional
just like a woman
because they their mindset
is the same as a female as their mother
so they act and think like women and
that's not going to change until they
forgive their mothers for
imposing her will and for turning them
away from their fathers and forgive the
father do you agree that all who are
born through the woman is born into sin
uh no i don't agree with that because
because what you're saying is that
yeah because not every child is born
into a dysfunctional household they are
all over the world
because god said all are born that way
they all are born into sin because they
were born through the woman oh he didn't
say psalm he just said
one maybe one out of a thousand all
that's why we all must be born again of
the father
okay so so this is what islam says and i
want our audience to judge you know
which uh you know what uh watch which
world view makes more sense
islam says that yes we are sometimes
product of the environment however god
gave us a right to gain education and
obligation to gain education and if we
do commit sin
and we all commit sin then there is a
pathway for forgiveness is open
directly repenting to god without any
mediator and without anyone dying for
our sins
god is all-knowing he's all loving he's
a good he's a merciful and forgiving god
i mean i'm a parent you know my child is
over here if he like does something
wrong right playing too much on the ipad
right i mean i don't like that i'm not
going to slap him if he comes to me and
says you know dad
okay please forgive me you know i'll be
more punctual i will read books i will
do my homework i will hug him i will
forgive him i will not take my other
innocent son for a price to be paid for
my son who has you know broken the house
rules in the same way even if i agree
with you that you know we are born into
households that may have all of these
sins and evils
but god is a forgiving god that's the
whole point the pathway to paradise is
not through anyone dying for us but us
asking for forgiveness reaching to god
praying to god following his guidance
and asking god's forgiveness
do are you so you're married
doctor yes sir
and your wife obey you
what do you mean by obey
does your wife obey you are you the head
of your wife
i'm the head of the household yes are
you the head of your wife
head of your wife i'm the head of the
whole household my children how about
your wife my children by the way are you
the head of your wife's part of the
household
okay head of head of the household or
head of the voice in islam we have a
different meaning so it cannot be yes
and no question
when i say i'm the head of the household
that also includes my wife
that means that yes
i have to take care of them i'm
responsible for them and they should be
mutual you know discussion for for the
decisions that we make as a whole family
so are you the husband of your
wife me the authority
are you the head of your wife yes
i'm sorry yes sir as she's part of the
household and she's part of the
household he was a part of the furniture
what was that is he a part of the
furniture
she's a human being just like you and me
your wife my wife all the humans are
human beings does he obey you
obeying
as long as it does not disobey god
does your wife obey you
he is not an unconditional obedience
jesse as long as that obedience does not
disobey god just like for example uh do
i obey the president of the usa i would
say yes and no depending upon you know
uh if if he's telling me to do wrong
things obviously i will disobey if i'm
going to tell her to do wrong things she
has to disobey me she has to you know
rebel against me and point me and
educate me towards god
obey you pastor jesse
there's a higher i have a follow-up
question for him with that does your
wife obey you
dr sebia
she does
in the bible does this tell the wife
obey your husband as long as
or does it tell the wife obey your
husband
well in the bible there is no any
conditions to it
why are you putting conditions on it
because i'm not a bible believer i'm an
islam believer just like jesus quran
tell the the wife to obey your husband
as long as
the quran and islam it generally
mentions that obedience first and
foremost has to be with god if anyone
contradicts that that obviously there is
no obedience to that person but
allegiance and obedience should be
directly towards the creator and you
understand why you tell the the woman in
the i mean the quran tell the woman to
only oh you obey your husband as long as
he's doing it the way
she thinks he should do it right
see in islam i can give you one example
by the way
children are going to have unconditional
obedience to the parents but then there
is a condition to it one condition right
if the parents are telling them to
worship someone else then the children
should disobey the parent in doing that
same thing for the wife
same thing for the wife with the analogy
applies
is that the way you're written in the
quran yes or exactly like that in the
bible but but just you can understand
this imagine if you're if you're for
instance if your wife says go get me
some uh the wife says the husband says
to the white go get me some alcohol or
go get me some lotto tickets or do
something else that is a clear sin haram
you are then respectfully to say listen
i'll get you some i'll get you some
water or i'll get you something else to
dream i'm not going to get you the
alcohol for instance that's just an
example so that's what he's talking
about let me ask you this jesse if you
let me ask your wife obey you eddie let
me ask you this just your wife obeying
you let me ask you this jesse look uh
you mentioned the quran being uh has it
been changed right and you mentioned how
the bible and i'm just trying to
understand this these are this is this
is not like uh what i was thinking that
you were trying when you mentioned the
term traps and stuff we're not trying to
trap uh set up traps or anything and we
have to have that
well i said that when i came on your
show you know because a lot of times let
me let me just define that why because a
lot of times what these news anchors
will do they'll try to invite a muslim
on and they'll try to get sound bites
and they'll ask them these yes and no
questions and they they'll end up you
know presenting a false distorted idea
of islam based on those things with the
cut in pace so we're that that's that's
the traps we're talking about doesn't
the bible say let your answer be yey or
no yes or no
let me ask you this what does the bible
say yes let your answers be yes or no
when did you get out of jail yes or no
did the bible say
let your answer be yes no when did you
get out when did you get out of jail yes
or no how long ago did you get out of
jail yes or
you're
no
answering my question but you're not
answering my question that's but i asked
you the question first what
let me let's jesse let's see jesse uh
you mentioned that
the
bible you're not going to answer that i
just like to understand i'll come back
to it uh
you can't give me a quick answer if the
bible says let your answer be yes or no
does the bible say that
does the bible say that no
you said no it doesn't say that
so so so brother jesse there's something
did you say it doesn't say that he said
it doesn't i was going to say i'd have
to look that up i don't want to just
talk off of my i don't i don't know i
don't want to talk off my whims see we
don't just make stuff up we you know
evidence the bible
that it says say yes or no let your
answers be yay or nay that means yes or
no
you said it doesn't
you say
okay so so brother jesse just look from
uh
you say you don't know if that's in the
bible or not
that particular verse you'd have to show
me
okay so you don't know if it's there or
not
i don't know oh okay
you don't know you don't know i haven't
come across it okay that makes sense if
you don't know i totally understand that
yeah so let me ask you this
there are certain questions
that doesn't have a yes and no answer by
the way as brother or eddie ask you the
question
you may think you know what it's not a
yes and no answer you have to give some
explanation and then answer it so not
every question can be a yes or no
question because that's not how life is
amazing so you have to understand that
and you have to respect that so before
we conclude just a couple more and i and
i want to know are you going to be
planning to visit chicago anytime soon
jesse what what part of the states are
you in where are you probably there in
july
in july yeah would you would you would
you i would ask you ahead of time would
you have lunch with me and dr sabile
i would love to i would definitely look
at my schedule and try to make leave
some space open for that uh dr bill i
mean would you be willing to sit with
doctor with um pastor jesse over lunch
yesterday uh jesse of course of course
and and it's our it's our treat okay
we're paying all right
amazing
here's what i'm trying to do
you need to you need to
you don't need to but i would suggest
you become the head of your wife
otherwise you're going to destroy your
children
you know what there's a hadith by
prophet muhammad who said he's saying he
said that the the shepherd for every
family is the man and the shepherd for
the children is the woman so each one of
you are shepherd you know so
god almighty is saying in the quran that
the the the righteous women are devoutly
obedient okay so they're divided into
righteous women so that's another topic
but a muslim is to be kind kind to his
wife to treat her honorably and a
righteous woman a wife is supposed to be
respectful towards her husband there's a
great great book i i had a guest
you can't find that in the world today
i'm getting distracted but remember
there's a there's a christian i
introvert her name is laura doyle it's
called the surrendered wife and she
listened to a woman
she talks about every time you listen to
the woman you will suffer
yeah yeah hey listen to this uh so tell
me about the bible right uh doctor
should be every time the man listens to
the woman doesn't he suffer no we don't
want to say that look listen
look of course not you know the mothers
the mothers of every single prophet
prophet moses and abraham and you know
even jesus
are you going to say that mary the pious
lady the chaste lady the honored lady
are you going to defame her by saying
that you know do not listen to mary no
jesus
you can't compare the women in the world
today with mary what the no because
because you you you just said you know
don't listen to any woman is everything
listen to her you will suffer
even to mary
where's mary now
it doesn't matter are you saying
she's a righteous lady she would be in
paradise obviously where is mary dr
sebel she's mentioned paradise and she
would be in paradise because she was a
righteous lady
do you know
you know this is important one woman on
earth today that could be compared to
mary and did you know that chapter 19 is
named after her in the quran it's surah
yes chapter miriam miriam it's in the
quran and you know that in islam
that
the heaven paradise is under the feet of
your mother so we're talking about a
mother needs to be respected children
don't respect their father needs to be
respected but i know what you're getting
toward jesse you're getting towards the
modern day feminism right that's a whole
different topic
i'm not getting into a that's part of
that's part of the whole
yeah the attack on masculinity
this is a totally different topic this
was your talk the whole alphabet
the whole turn
uh the man's children away from him the
divorce system i just talked
no
no
the marriage system and the non-marriage
system any woman that turned
the man's children away from him it's
evil
then a feminist
no different than a woman that's evil
yeah that's evil
well we can't blame all women like just
like we can't blame all men but i
understand i hear what you're saying
that we have to blame all women what do
you mean by that if any person if a man
turns his children away talking about
women man
yeah let me ask you this before because
that's a different type maybe we could
talk about the other other i just as a
pastor pastor jesse i'm trying to
understand do you do you do you uh
believe that the bible has been changed
because you alluded to the fact that
maybe something was taken out of the
quran but the quran is the verbatim word
of god almighty tamper-free temper proof
that's one of the miracles of the quran
that we have it today as it was
preserved we have it and anyone who
comes at it objectively scientifically
analytically and they approach it
they'll see there's no way this can come
from anyone other than the creator that
has on earth but let me tell me do you
believe the bible because i heard you
say it and i want to just hear from you
do you believe the bible has been
tampered with has been changed because
you know as a pastor that matthew didn't
write matthew luke didn't write luke
it's according to matthew according to
luke and no credible bible scholar will
tell you that matthew wrote matthew so
that's the leading question
okay so how would you yes or no is the
bible been changed i'll just do like i
may i'll do like you do
as the has the has the bible belongs now
through the years yeah help us
understand just men have rewritten the
bible in order to fit in with the
culture
rather than making the culture fit in
with what's right they have changed
about the wordings of the bible that's
why god not the only reason but one of
the reasons god put the spirit upon our
heart we have a teacher within
and that is the holy spirit and that's
why god said let no man teach you
because if another man teaches you
they're going to intellectually teach
you right into hell
but if you hear what they have to say
let it pass through one through one ear
and out the other one but allow only the
holy spirit to teach you you cannot go
wrong
so how do you decipher now
so if i understood you correctly do you
do agree that the bible's been changed
how does someone decipher what's the
word of god like there's many passages
that are really clear and lucid where dr
sabil was mentioning that the passage of
hero israel the lord thy god is one
you know that jesus being subordinate to
god that he prayed to god we would say
those
are in line with what we believe that
jesus was worshiping the creator calling
people away from idol worship away from
immorality we'd agree but then you have
other passages in there that we would
disagree with like the passages that
paint some of the prophets is committing
immoral acts and whatnot we would say
this is the hands of man this is not to
disrespect you as a christian or
anything but we would say that this is
like because you said you said this is
the bible's been changed and and if it's
changed people are adding deleting so
this is where we would say and take
strong offense when they insult many of
the god's prophets and messengers and
they attribute things vices to them sins
to them that we would say there's no way
because the prophets are perfect well
apparently the quran has been changed
too because it was definitely in there
where it says christians and jews are
infidel worthy of death
and that you can lie to them you could
be frustrated
we're doing it again
jesse where are you going we did this
yeah so so just like apparently the it
sounds like the quran has been
re-written so has the bible been
re-written and is set up to deceive the
people and not to set them free but to
control them
so brother jesse uh historically we know
and i can show you the evidence that the
bible that you're assumed that you are
also acknowledging has been changed new
testament and old testament right but
that process did not happen to the quran
from the time the quran was given to
prophet muhammad peace be upon him from
god he memorized the whole quran he had
it written down
thousands and millions of people all
throughout the ages they memorized the
whole quran and we have the copies of
the quran going all the way back to the
first generation so the quran has not
been changed because allah god promises
in the quran that god will protect it so
the quran can't tell me that it's not
there about infidels the christians and
jews and what you could lie to them to
see them you could feed them whatever
right but that was not there now maybe
that has been taken out i won't argue
that because i haven't i haven't seen
the new quran i just saw the real ones
where those things were there
and so they may have been changed they
may not be there today because
um
i've noticed that when the muslim move
into the christian world
western society their whole mission is
to destroy the western society to
destroy christianity so maybe that has
been changed
are you really do you really believe the
stuff that you're saying jesse
is happening
so so jesse
you know
and you know because we're because as
muslims we're commanded
we're commanded we're not there
we're commanded to to spread good and
forbid evil uh to uh like i said to hate
injustices you know to be just so how
can we like it's it's a contradiction
it's it doesn't make sense jesse we
don't see the muslim out there
denouncing
they're not they're not out there
denouncing that christian the koran is
wrong
i'm saying that christians but jews are
infidels do you hear yourself just that
you could just
where are the muslims i don't see
numbers a muslim denouncing that at all
jesse jesse do you see christians
denouncing hallelujah
who is hallelujah
[Laughter]
do you see the christians denying any
passage of the bible
what does that have to do with the quran
the muslim not denouncing that
christians and jews are infidels and
worthy of death
so okay so me as a muslim i will not
deny
that what you're saying because the
quran does not say to begin with it's
not even there in the quran brother
jesus
may be rewritten so no no
today no
people have memorized the whole quran
suppose if somebody comes and adds
something to the quran for example there
are millions of memorizers out there
they will catch it they will correct it
they will throw this copy out if
somebody adds something to it and that
process is a check and balance process
that you will not find for the bible for
the old new testament the quran has a
dual check and balance system so what we
have in our hands the arabic quran is
exactly the same that was given by god
to prophet muhammad peace be upon him it
has not been changed later on maybe in a
different episodes we can go over the
process how the quran has been protected
by god zero change
not a single letter not a single word
not a single chapter but let me ask you
this question
why do i believe in the passages that
you are mentioning from the bible
that man is the head of the household or
head of his wife the bible doesn't say
that the man is the head of the
household the bible says that the
husband is the head of the wife
and being like you might be ahead of
your wife you are afraid to say that
you're ahead of your wife or you know
what's going on
so so jesse why should you believe in
that man
okay
why would you why
no no hold on brother why should you
believe in that because that may be
somebody changed it somebody inserted
that since bible has been changed why
should i risk my life of eternity in a
book that is less than hundred percent
yeah
don't risk your life like that because i
don't want your wife to hurt you when
you try to be the man but
christianity there's an order to life
and that order is god in christ christ
in man man over woman and woman over
children and that's the only thing
that's going to work and that's why
everything else is a false imitation of
that
and it's not working and that's why men
must return to the father
so if they decide they do want a family
a wife and children they would be the
head of their wife and they would not
even think of marrying a woman who is
unwilling to obey him because it's
just going to be hell in the home if
she's unwilling to obey her husband so
brother jesse where did you get your
notion that a man is the head of the
wife where did you get that from from
god
wait did he just reveal that to you or
is it from the bible it's written into
scriptures and once you were born of the
father you can see it for yourself do
you believe in the bible
no you don't
you don't believe in the bible why you
you quote the bible more than a
christian why are you trying to prove
that the bible is raw no
because you believe in the bible that's
the reason i'm quoting it not because i
believe in it because you don't hear me
quote the bible like that you're quoting
more than the scriptures i mean more
than christians
do
do you believe in the bible at all
there are certain passages in the bible
brother jesse that aligns with the quran
and they may be at one time the verse of
the original scripture that god gave to
jesus but you know and i know that
people have changed the bible for that
reason and i changed the quran as well
apparently
no no we can give you the evidence i'm
giving you the evidence
that people have memorized the whole
quran both me and eddie we memorize big
chunks of them why you need to
rememberize the whole quran why you need
to remember it
it's a miracle it's amazing you don't
trust that the holy spirit will bring
all things to your memories
okay
uh if if the holy spirit was there no no
i'll ask you a question first and then
you can follow up on it do you trust and
then i gotta go because i gotta some
work at the bottom of this hour
do you trust that the holy spirit will
bring all things to your memories
see we we trust god that god is the one
that's not the question
do you believe that the holy spirit will
bring all things to your remembrance
see we don't believe in the holy spirit
we believe in god
yeah so we say that god is the one who
is in control
and god is the one who is protecting the
quran in the hearts and the minds of
people
so when we memorize it it's ultimately
god who's protecting the quran through
the humans and through the writing
but before you go brother jesse you know
before you the holy spirit at all
no god is god and there is no one else
besides god because the bible itself
says and the quran also says this by the
way
and the and the reason i'm mentioning
the bible because you believe in it not
that i believe in it did i say i believe
in the bible when did i say i believed
in the bible you don't
you say you don't believe in the bible
but aren't you a pastor don't you quote
from the bible if you don't believe in
the bible why don't you quote it
once in hawaii i'll throw something out
there but my belief is in god i believe
in no book and no man i believe in god
and the bible so you're a pastor who
doesn't believe in the bible so your
bible the bible
you're a pastor who doesn't believe in
the
bible it's so important yes sir the
bible is the word from god but the word
of god is written in our hearts the word
flesh whose heart because we're praying
for muslims
no no because my neighbor who is a
christian he may say you know what
god is jesus is not son of god and he's
a christian and he will deny you and he
will say that god has implanted his word
in my heart who am i going to believe
you or him he may say the same thing
if you believe it just because i said it
it's just an intellectual belief that
will get you nowhere you will still
suffer in this world but if you believe
it because it's been revealed to you you
can see it for yourself it's then you
got it and you know the truth
the father has revealed that to you
isn't this subjective isn't this that
somebody can just make up things as they
go along jesse don't we need evidence
the bible thumpers and it's not because
because if i understand you correctly
now you don't even believe that the
bible is the word of god the bible is
the word from god the word of god is
made flesh in our hearts i'm confused
that's why god said the kingdom of
heaven is within
and that i give you a new reality in the
new testament is about the kingdom of
heaven being within don't look without
the answer is not out there it's inside
of us
you must know yourself and knowing
yourself you'll get to know god you must
live from within and not without so
before we conclude we got some things uh
out and we discussed it and you agree
that obviously like like we do that the
bible text has been changed and and and
now that's why god almighty and the
quran and that dr sebil gave the
evidence that it wasn't anybody can look
you know no i wasn't
i'm black and slow but i'm not that
black and slow i've read in the quran
that
christians and jews are infidels
worthy of death
you can lie to them to the muslim youth
you can you know there's a challenge
i challenge i i challenge you
how much money you want
dr bill how much wanted to destroy the
infidels if you can produce that
there's a there's a million-dollar
challenge now if you can come up you
know with that from the quran you're
going to get paid now so we could put
that to rest like that's give me a
million dollars you could go if you
could produce something like that go
ahead give me a million dollars you're
going to dr buick how much are we going
to give him if he could produce
something a million how much you're
going to get
right now he said he just said 2 million
you got 2 million plus the 1 that's 3
million now
look look how easy look how easy this is
look uh look if we look out and i'll
just make this contrast if we go and you
say this is in the bible we would go
back to what you have with the original
but we don't have original bible but
today we have the quran it's original so
you can just go and look to see if this
word even infidel is in there and you're
not going to find it so you guys offered
me three million dollars right three
million all right to show i can't
i gotta go right now i have appointment
right now so okay i'll i'll leave you
let's leave you with this you talk about
silent prayer this is what i earnestly
ask all of us to do is that we pray to
god almighty alone that we ask for
guidance that god the creator of the
heavens and earth the god that jesus
prayed to the god that moses abraham the
last defilement sent to mankind that we
ask him for guidance you can't how can
you go wrong doing that the one creator
that heavens on earth to guide us and
this is the one that we should be loving
with all our heart our mind our body and
the soul
you must be still and know him because
when you ask you ask the myth you ask
ego you don't know what you want you
don't know what you need that's why if
you be still and know him he will take
over and all your needs will be met
but when you ask you're asking out of
selfishness you don't know what you want
you don't know so be still and know the
father don't have to rip
wine and bank and all that but i gotta
go i want you guys to go to
i want the people to go to
jesselypeterson.com
jesseleypederson.com and
rebuildingtheman.com
rebuildingtheman.com and they can learn
more about what we are doing so brother
jesse just give me 30 seconds
all right we got 30 seconds man 25 go
all right go ahead we believe that there
is only one god the god of moses jesus
abraham all the prophets he loves
humanity and he chose from the humans
messengers and prophets so we have to
believe in the creator follow his
guidance
brother one second so then we have to
see this scripture has the guidance if
the bible has been changed according to
you we can show and we have proven to
you the quran has not been changed quran
has comprehensive guidance solutions
against racism drug problem homicide you
know breakdown of the family scriptures
of the family's you know structure
by being the best person obeying god's
guidance and follow and obeying god
by god's mercy that's how a person goes
to paradise
no you go to paradise by
being born again of the father otherwise
you're getting into paradise not our god
paradigm maybe to the muslim god
paradise
where the twelve wives are waiting for
them but you're getting into paradise
unless you up to four four jesse up to
four jesse listen
up five seconds five seconds right five
seconds brother anyone who would like to
read the quran we can send you a free
copy of the quran english translation
please call us 1-800
1-800-662-islam or go to gainpeace.com
please read the quran brother jesse may
god guide and bless you brother we'll
see you in chicago jesse all right
amazing holy
look it up there's no god but god that's
it that's the message take care all
right thank you guys i appreciate you in
chicago bye-bye okay
all right guys that was uh uh pastor
jesse who runs one of the
popular christian conservative talk
shows here in america and we're
sincerely trying to build a lot of those
bridges with the conservative christians
and others
people out there who are trying to
establish good in their lives
who want to see their children come up
in a positive light
you know in a in a positive
uh atmosphere
this is what islam is all about and
we're trying to connect with our
christian friends and our neighbors and
having them come to us to learn and
hopefully we've cleared up some of these
misconceptions dr sabil what was your
takeaway in the last few minutes that we
have from our conversation with pastor
jesse reverend jesse peterson
yeah i mean it's a really it's really uh
you know a pleasure having him in the
sense that he is at least willing to
come and listen he may agree he may not
agree but at least the job of a muslim
is not to force anyone but with love and
compassion using wisdom we have to
explain to brother jesse and the rest of
humanity that there is one creator
and there is the rest of us we are all
creations of god and god loves us he
wants to guide us so to guide us he
appointed messengers and prophets
and
submission to one god is what islam is
so as people moved away from islam in
the time of jesus moses and different
times
god appointed messengers and prophets to
bring these people back again
so that's the bigger message that we
want to give to brother jesse and to all
of us and we hope and pray that maybe in
a sequel maybe in a different discussion
we can have specific topics compared to
jumping all over the place and we hope
and pray that those who are watching us
you pick up a copy of the quran and not
make up your mind about islam based upon
what you see in the media based upon
those people who are not muslims learn
islam from the muslims knowledgeable
muslims and go and read the sources of
islam
the quran which is the word of god and
the sunnah which is the practices of
prophet muhammad peace be upon him
and i think those talking points that
jesse mentions and i wanted to
have
some kind of understanding because a lot
of the programming that's going on and
maybe just years and years he's coming
up in age i want to be very respectful
to him and you know a lot of the
conditioning so it's things don't just
happen overnight but if we're sincere
and our minds are open our hearts are
open and now these are simple things
that a person can look up like the
things that he brought up dr bill about
you know his cur the quran teaching to
deceive you know
others the christians and jews to so you
could just end up destroying all this
other nonsense i mean the muslims out
here are hearing this i mean that means
we would have to be perpetuating a lie
to ourselves to our followers when the
text you can open it and you can see for
yourself and you gave some some great
examples this this has been debunked
this is i'm just surprised that people
actually like like himself and others
believe this type of stuff you know and
you look at the quran where allah is
talking about that
the quran is saying that o muhammad
we've sent you as a mercy to all of
mankind so how could a mercy to mankind
people who wish peace upon other people
want to destroy other people and you and
you quoted the ayah from the quran
chapter 60 verse 8 that if people are
not persecuting you and driving you out
of your homes like
you have this war going on between the
russians and ukraines and the whole
world understands now you know one
invading
country coming to another and these
people are looked at as heroes and
they're saving their homeland and
whatnot but when the muslims do that now
they're looked at as what terrorists and
whatnot so he understood that when we
were talking about it what a struggle is
against evil and this is just common
sense but when you look at the facts
from the text you know you have so many
so many examples where you can give you
know what i mean you know
and and and so many uh textual proofs
that anybody who looks at the quran
objectively sincerely and the life of
prophet muhammad doesn't cherry pick cut
and paste we'll see that look you know
what's truth and what's falsehood so i
thought this was very important you know
the whole concept doxabill they bring up
takia you know deceiving lying and just
i i thought these things got faded out
and it just surprising that they come
and they they come back up you know
again and uh it's just like uh it
reminds me how a muslim is is able to
even marry a christian right or a jew
how how are you going to hate your own
wife you know if you or marry her if you
are taught from a young age as as he
said in others to just lie and deceive
you know to what it doesn't make any
sense you know what uh is important for
the viewers and also for me and for all
of us is that we should never ever judge
a faith based upon the not so good
followers of that faith
because if i'm going to judge
christianity or the bible or jesus based
upon the crusades the spanish
inquisition
uh the slave traders and the genocide of
the native americans
and all the heinous crimes done in the
name of christianity i am not doing
justice to christianity or the bible by
looking into the actions of the people
in the same way there may be some
muslims out there right who may doing
acts which goes against the teachings of
islam we have to condemn them
just like we want to condemn those jews
and krishnas and muslims and buddhists
and hindus who are going against the
human decency human morality and doing
oppression
so the bottom line is separate the
actions of the people from the beautiful
teachings of islam
come to the teachings of islam pick up a
copy of the quran do not believe anyone
not even us pick up a copy of the quran
and you will see
that islam stands for justice and unity
and peace obedience to the creator our
destination is paradise
obeying to the creator not worshiping
jesus moses trinity or any creation any
animal worshiping only one god
taking all the prophets as honored
people following them taking example of
prophet muhammad peace be upon him as a
final prophet we will see that there
would be justice in the world there
would be morality the problems are going
to go away
but the best gift the best reward would
be
through god's guidance through god's
mercy eternal paradise
that's what we want to invite you
and i hope and pray that you look into
islam and then you pick up a copy of the
quran and hopefully obey and submit to
the one creator and we have that
available now at thedeenshow.com free
copy of the quran and again again i mean
i stress if you
get the quran you read it for yourself
and you'll see for yourself
and not let others think for you and not
let others deceive you you know because
i think a lot of times oxford people end
up projecting you know their own uh hate
and they ha they end up you know
projecting some of these ill feelings
they have inside and try to put it push
it on muslims or push it on islam which
it has nothing you know to to do or they
end up cherry picking cutting and
pasting and and i think this was such a
very
important conversations you know and
then you have also people unfortunately
who've jumped on the bandwagon it's
become a business you know entertaining
people who like this kind of hate who
you know fostering manufacturing this
fear manufacturing a lot of this false
information putting the stuff out there
you know feeding into this and you got
people paid into individuals you know
who do this for a living and now if they
end up changing their stance or their
approach they're going to lose a lot of
clientele you found me so that's the
really important thing for our audience
everybody jesse other pastors who watch
these christians you know i often say we
have to work together we got so many
different attacks on our family our
morality all of these things that are
out there that we could be working
together and over here we're getting
sidelines with many of these other
things if you have a sincere question
you know call us 1-800-662-4742
read the quran sit with us break bread
with us you know visit uh a muslims
visit the mosque come to one of the open
houses and learn for yourself you know
if you and if you're sincere and you
want to know
you're going to end up learning but if
you're just you're you're your mind is
not open and you just come in you know
playing these games and setting traps
and whatnot you know you're just looking
for something that's going to feed into
this hate that you already have
you're not going to get anywhere your
heart's close your mind is close your
your eyes are closed at the end of the
day one important thing is that the
reality is that every single one of us
we have to die
and then god is going to bring us back
to life there would be a day of
resurrection and every single one of us
would be standing individually in front
of god
and then god would be uh
taking us into account how did we live
this life did we followed only one god
and did we do good deeds the way that he
wants us to do on that day brother eddie
no one is going to have an excuse
that my colleague made me do that my
pastor made me do that you know my
neighbor made me do that because god is
going to say i gave you the guidance i
gave you the right from the wrong why
did you follow the wrong at that point
we cannot have any excuses why did we
not believe in only one god why did we
worship a man a human jesus
why did we worship an idol why did we
worship an animal at that point we
cannot come back to this wall again on
the day of judgement so now is the time
now is the life that we have to think
let's not uh get brainwashed by some
people god gave us a beautiful mind a
mind to think and ponder
analyze god is god jesus is
a human he used to eat he used to sleep
he got tired
he brought oxygen so he was a human
hundred percent human zero percent god
just like jesus and just like moses and
abraham before him and last prophet
prophet muhammad peace be upon him after
him
so let's hope and pray that all of us we
think about you know who god is
and who jesus was
and come to the creator pick up a copy
and inshaallah god willing if you have a
sincere heart god will guide you pray to
the one creator for guidance
and uh we kind of having a post analysis
we kind of we went way over time but i
think this is something very important
because you will have a lot of
christians watching this and not not a
lot of not yet muslims and how can you
begin a conversation dr sebia with
someone when
the you have suspicion about what
they're saying the the term tequila is
thrown out these these people are just
deceiving you like he just he kept uh
they keep repeating like you know
they're taught from a young age to just
deceive you you know to lie to you you
know
but if if someone is sincere and they're
they can see through all this they're
going to get upset that now they believe
a lot of these lies that were put out
there to keep you from the truth to keep
you because the truth is one and the
truth is easy to understand so when you
are men you keep mentioning god is one
worship god alone
you talk about all of these things that
go with the fitra they go with the human
nature so are you the question would be
are you are you dark sibil deceiving
someone to believe in one god so if
someone does all these things that islam
is calling to they're respectful to
their parents
they live a morally upright life
they don't gamble they don't drink
alcohol they don't fornicate you know no
sex outside of marriage you might fall
into these things and god is the most
merciful and you turn you to your
creator that doesn't take you out of
islam but now you turn your way back and
you pray to only one god the same god
that jesus worship the one and only one
god my question is where's the the lie
there you know if someone does that
that's gonna make their life they're
gonna become a better human being
where's the deception i mean it's just
logically time it's just it's so like
you know uh
it is so absurd it just makes the the
more you think about the more absurd it
becomes it doesn't it doesn't makes uh
no sense
yeah i mean at the at the end of the day
right there is so much there on the
social media but as i said already every
person would be accountable on the day
of judgement there would not be any
excuse that he made me do it you know
satan made me do that they will als all
they will all say you know what i we
just told you this you you had your own
mind your own brain god has given all of
us
a mind to think and ponder and research
and with sincere heart
as for god's guidance
so at the end of the day we would say
that
there is a creator
all the books cannot be from god either
the bible is from god or the quran or
none of them both cannot be from god so
think and ponder if some book that has
been changed i cannot my risk i cannot
risk my life in eternity on a book that
has been changed
compared to a quran which has not been
changed and we have shown on we have
given evidence to the pastor
it has been memorized it has been
written down so it's a dual check of
balance system for the quran
so we hope and pray that our sincere
christians and people of other faiths
look into islam islam is not a new faith
by the way jesus was a muslim because he
used to submit and worship to one god so
were moses and abraham and ishmael and
isaac so if you love god follow the
faith of jesus the faith of jesus was
islam submission to the one creator and
you even had our our friend jesse admit
that the bible's been changed i imagine
having an imam come on and say the
quran's been changed that means
everything falls apart because once a
book is changed it cannot be from god
and then there's the there's the whole
thing with the words it's fr it's it's
what was the thing it was i don't want
to misquote anybody but it's from it's
not a god's word but it's from god what
was the the wording
yeah something like that it's from god
but that is just playing with the words
because
if if he's going to quote the bible
then how does he know that what he's
quoting is not the changed inserted
passages yeah
then yeah so then the whole thing just
gets destroyed that's why god almighty
sent the last the final revelation said
to mankind but i think people get stuck
thinking like okay why is this messenger
white why isn't he blue-eyed the racism
kicks in whatever your mind has to be
open jesus actually was a palestinian
was he not he was an heir he was from
that part of the world so you know
when you look at it like he wasn't
blonde hair blue-eyed you know how a
person has made him look so i we have to
eliminate this racism we have to like
you know uh get this uh these these
missed notions and a lot of these uh
biases away from us and truly come to
the creator with a pure heart you know
and ask for guidance sincerely directly
to god almighty alone and then god
almighty will guide us but we can't come
with these prejudices this racism and
this you know all of these evil things
and now we we're playing you know
we're we're playing with the guide we're
not really sincerely seeking the
guidance and this is what is so
important we leave you with that to seek
earnestly
the guidance from the one god the
creator of the heavens and earth calling
to god alone guide me guide me guide me
i leave you with that homework you also
get the quran at the deanshow.com look
at it for yourself okay and call the
number thank you very much dr bill thank
you very much again we went over time
but this is a very important episode
uh that so many christians will be
watching some pastors because we had one
of the top conservative christians on
the program and we were hopefully this
can be a catalyst for other conservative
christians to come on the program and
let us talk
let us talk break bread together and let
us go ahead and try to understand each
other better and get this fear out of
the way of the unknown of
of not understanding because of people
being ignorant come get educated come
talk to us
uh and thank you dr bill again
alhamdulillah may allah guide all of us
may god bless all of us may allah make
all of us as submitters to the creator
the way jesus was and may god by his
mercy induct us into eternal paradise
amen all right salaam like a peace be
with you
and peace be with you assalamu alaikum
thank you guys see you next time here on
the dean show
and if you like this episode of the dean
show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum